here's what would happen if you were  attacked by a bear  your defense strategy would depend on  what kind of bear you were facing black  bears don't usually attack in sudden  encounters these Bears generally attack  in self-defense but if a black bear  chased you up a tree you're probably in  danger they're climbers you wouldn't  need to worry about a black bear's speed  of 40 kilometers an hour and its  strength Grizzlies are Speedy Hunters  too their massive Jaws have a bite force  of  8274 kilopascals so if a Grizzly pinned  you down taking the risk and playing  dead might just be the way to save your  life now a polar bear would use its  exceptionally sharp sense of smell to  sniff you out watch out for those claws  One swipe from a polar bear could snap  your spine fortunately these bears are  usually confined to The Frigid deserts  of the Arctic Circle but